growing up did you ever do anything that
kind of worried your parents were you
like a not a good kid but were you like
one they didn't worry about or when they
were like oh he's gonna try and jump off
the roof uh I so here's a here's the
deal is that I was actually like really
well behaved yeah whereas Joe and Kevin
at times were were not yeah
yeah okay I don't know
I remember
my first time ever swimming we lived in
this apartment complex in Dallas Texas
and
um there was a fence around the pool and
it was like the start of uh kind of the
winter season so Not only was it cold
but also the pool was shut and locked
because it was dangerous for kids to go
swimming but for some reason at like
three or four years old I just decided
it would be a good idea to like hop the
fence and just go for a swim
and my mom of course like ran after me
as I just like climbed over this fence
and so I would do these things that were
so out of character and just like nearly
uh fatal and and I always do that yeah
exactly yeah I recognize you know my mom
was very patient and I'm sure I gave her
a lot of scares but yeah other than that
I was pretty well behaved apart from
nearly you know driving far from nearly
dying in a pool
um oh my gosh I can't imagine I put my
kids in swim lessons like because they
were babies because I was so worried
about that you hear those like horror
stories I feel like you're probably the
most patient dad on planet Earth are you
I mean I I try to be yeah our dad was
very patient
um well you and John when I work with
you on the voice I feel like you're both
kind of you could both be walking Ambien
like you're both like that chill like
they're both that chill and I'm I know I
think because I'm opposite I'm always
like like John especially John
especially he is the one I actually call
walking Ambience yes so chill he is so
chill that I thought he was stoned every
time I saw him turns out he doesn't even
get high like I was like what it was the
craziest thing ever finding that
information out but I feel like you're a
really patient dad that's gonna serve
you well because you're gonna need it
yeah yeah she hasn't started walking yet
but I'm sure when she does yeah it's
gonna be patience and uh comfortable
shoes because I'll be running after her
100 and just getting old because you
turned 30 last year so you're gonna need
those Dr scholes yes oh I have insoles
in my shoes right now I have insoles
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]